My fellow Americans, tonight I want to speak with you...
...about our nation's unprecedented response to the coronavirus outbreak that started in China...
...and is now spreading throughout the world.
Today, the World Health Organization officially announced that this is a global pandemic.
We have been in frequent contact with our allies...
...and we are marshaling the full power of the federal government and the private sector...
...to protect the American people.
This is the most aggressive and comprehensive effort to confront a foreign virus in modern history.
I am confident that by counting and continuing to take these tough measures,...
....we will significantly reduce the threat to our citizens...
...and we'll ultimately and expeditiously defeat this virus.
At the very start of the outbreak, we instituted sweeping travel restrictions on China...
...and put in place the first federally mandated quarantine in over 50 years.
We declared a public health emergency...
...and issued the highest level of travel warning on other countries...
...as the virus spread its horrible infection.
The European Union failed to take the same precautions and restrict travel from China and other hotspots.
As a result, a large number of new clusters in the United States were seeded by travelers from Europe.
After consulting with our top government health professionals,...
...I have decided to take several strong but necessary actions...
...to protect the health and well-being of all Americans.
To keep new cases from entering our shores,...
...we will be suspending all travel from Europe to the United States for the next 30 days.
The new rules will go into effect Friday at midnight.